hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast novel pet radio chemistry
improving understanding and detection of
disease presented by Timothy degrade Oh
PhD and Roger Shibley PhD we are excited
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by perkin-elmer PerkinElmer is
a global leader focused on improving the
health and safety of people and the
environment the company provides
scientists solutions to accelerate their
research through its innovative
detection imaging services and
informatics platforms a leader in
preclinical optical imaging perkinelmer
now offers the G platform of PET
scanners the g4 pet x-ray and g8 pet-ct
that will be discussed today to
complement their ibis optical and
quantum micro-ct systems PerkinElmer
preclinical imaging solutions support
the discovery of critical insights and
disease progression and therapeutic
responses in oncology cardiology
infectious disease and other disease
areas to learn more about PerkinElmer
please visit www m I am Judy O'Rourke of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on your screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
two and a button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you now
I'd like to introduce dr. degrade oh and
dr. shibly dr. degrade o is a professor
of radiology at the Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota and direct
molecular imaging laboratory he has 30
plus years experience in radio chemistry
radio isotope production radio
pharmacology PET imaging and radio
pharmaceutical development dr. grago has
focused his career on developing
metabolic radio pharmaceuticals and has
brought several agents through
preclinical animal and clinical
translation including 18 s plural
choline which is now used routinely in
many countries for imaging prostate
cancer dr. shibly is an associate
professor in the Department of Chemistry
and applied Biosciences at ETH Zurich
and head of the center for radio
pharmaceutical science a joint endeavor
between the eth zurich the paul scherrer
institute and the university hospital
zurich professor shimmies research
interests focus on targeted tumor
diagnosis and therapy using radio
labelled compounds apart from the
chemical modification and radioactive
labeling of molecules is group places
emphasis on the biological and
pharmacological characterization and
optimization of the radioactive
compounds including non-invasive pet and
SPECT imaging the speaker's complete
BIOS are found on the lab roots website
please join me in welcoming dr. degrade
oh I will now turn the presentation over
to him thank you Judy and welcome
everyone I'm glad to present our
research and some concepts on cell
trafficking with positron emission
tomography or PET I have I'm sorry my
cursor is not there there it goes thanks
for hanging in there with me for a
disclosure on the co-inventor on a Mayo
Clinic submitted patent on zirconium 89
labeling of cells will be talking a
little bit about that later my outline
is I'll talk a little bit on
applications for cell tracking some of
the pros and cons of pet versus MRI for
imaging of cell trafficking and then
look more closely at the pet approaches
both the direct cell labeling approach
as well as the indirect cell labeling
approach
so what are some of the applications
well first of all regenerative medicine
is now pretty much exploding with the
use of cell therapies that is cells that
are engineered to target at issue that
is undergone some type of disease
process and we want to regenerate it and
get this tissue back to functional
status so first of all we want to know
well when we inject these cells or
administer these cells what are the
kinetics of these cells in vivo after
administration so some of the questions
we asked our where are they going that
is and can we selectively target the
tissues by engineering the cells or
changing the way we administer the cells
to to the body so that we can enhance
the regenerative potential will also
want to know what fraction of the cells
are hitting the target is it just five
percent or are we getting a robust
homing of the cells to the target and
then once they have hit the target
tissue are they retain their or do they
simply clear very rapidly and therefore
not have much of a chance to affect
their their their target and in this
regard we have to understand what are
the body's clearance mechanisms that
handle these cells and also not only the
cells but the the label that we give
them in order to image image these cells
in vivo also will want to know
information on the status of these
administered cells the ones that we're
tracking will want to know are these
cells remaining viable once they're
administered to the tissue or are they
dying quickly and therefore not having a
chance to have much of an effect are
they functional there are they are they
reproducing are there differentiating
are they or are they simply exerting
their effects in direct such as
expressing cofactors or cytokines or
whatnot that the the rest of the body
reacts to we really are in an early
stage to understand the effects of these
cells and image
has the potential to start to answer
these questions in a non-invasive manner
just quickly to look at the pros and
cons of using MRI versus pet starting
with MRI MRI of course gives us high
spatial resolution for an atomic
characterization there's no ionize a
lion izing radiation involved mainly
we've seen in literature iron labeled
cells so these are iron oxide particles
that are taken up by the cells before
they're administered for imaging we have
to understand the residual ization of
this label and the potential for
toxicity of these cells and this
technique is only useful for direct
labeling of the cells and injecting them
into the body for pet of course one of
the major strengths of pet is its high
imaging sensitivity it allows
quantitation for getting parameters out
that that are quantitative and scale
with the number for example a number of
cells or the enzymes that are expressing
gene reporter proteins potential for low
toxicity because of the low mass
associated with the pet labeling there's
functional characterization especially
for indirect labeling of the cells so we
have two ways of going about with pet
the so-called direct labeling with with
an isotope before injection and the
indirect or in vivo cell labeling where
you have gene reporter systems let's
start with the direct labeling and look
at the pet isotopes that are available
and I just listed them here in order of
half life going from shorter to longer
the cells have been labeled with fdg
successfully and used for tracking
copper 64 with pts m as the key later
for labeling of the cells and also
cercone m89 which has a longer three-day
half-life which which allows longer
observation periods manganese 52 is hit
the literature just
very recently with a longer half-life of
nearly six days although not much has
been done with manganese yet I think
we'll see more activity they're just
starting with fdg fdg has been used to
look at the trafficking of endothelial
progenitor cells here from Tamara dal we
see fdg labelled epcs injected into
tumor-bearing rats and you can see in
the I will try to give you a arrow here
you can see as a function of time the
movement of the of these labeled cells
these are these are FF 18 pet micro pet
studies here going from zero out to 90
minutes remember fdg has just a two hour
half life so we're looking at the early
distribution of these cells and you can
see them being taken up into this tumor
here you can see the quantitation
showing most of the cells homing to the
tumor quite nicely this this was a study
looked at the effects of gamma radiation
which stimulates blood flow and
angiogenesis and neovascular formation
in these tumor cells and these epc's
were able to track that in another study
by Kang Adele fdg was labeling
haemopoietic stem cells after
administration to patients with
myocardial infarction they looked at two
different ways to administer these cells
one was through IV injection shown here
on the right showing up taking the lungs
liver and spleen there as well as
intracoronary injection where you
actually do see specific uptake in the
myocardium so the distribution of these
stem cells of course relates very
closely to the administration of these
cells and here they were able to see the
uptake in the myocardium of these stem
cells
that were injected through the through
the coronary artery of course the
half-life of fdg two hours is not going
to give you much signal at 20 hours
after injection you can see very little
signal a little bit but in the heart
lingering in the heart after injection
of these stem cells it would be nice to
have a longer lived isotope for labeling
cells for pet so they're condom 89 may
fit the bill at least with a free day
half life you have you can you can go
out to at least a couple of weeks with
observations and initially researchers
at NIH satoh Adele as well as King's
College in London have developed a
zirconium 89 och seen cell labeling
methods shown here whereby the ox seen
zirconium 89 oxime is incubated with
cells in PBS and they're getting thirty
to forty percent labeling efficiency of
these cells and the folks at NIH did
show that the the label does not have a
significant impact on the viability of
these cells shown shown here with and
without the zirconium 89 you get about
the same amount of drop of viability in
the cells over time and the labeling
retention pretty much parallels the
number of cells over time and the
activity functional activity of these
dendritic cells in this case maintained
fairly high over eighty percent
functionality and they injected these
into my mice and you can see the the
uptake initially in the lungs and later
on it goes into the liver whereas when
they labeled cytotoxic T cells these T
cells again started at the lung but then
migrated over to spleen and also that
you could see some sights in the in
lymph nodes shown in the orange arrows
we've developed a new labeling method
which uses a new precursor we called ebn
it is a since on that we initially label
with
conium 89 you can see the synth on vbn
here we have to label this with
biologically compatible zirconium 89 so
we use a zoo conium 89 in a phosphate
buffer for the incubation we in cube 8
30 minutes at 37 degrees and we get the
DB n then we label the cells with that
also at 37 degrees it's a direct
labeling we don't pre isolate the DB n
we incubate the cells and then separate
the labeled cells from the from the the
DB n later and the the free zirconium
later with this technique we validated
that it is a useful for labeling a
variety of cells such as melanoma cells
stem cells dendritic cells here we
express the activity per million cells
we in our initial studies was about
point for 2.5 mega becquerels per
million cells we did show that the the
labeling is actually labeling the the
cell membrane wall and let me just go
back to the last slide because this DVN
has the NCS group here it labels primary
amines at the cell surface so we're not
we're not incubating to get inside the
cell but actually having a reaction a
covalent reaction at the cell surface
and that really retains the activity on
the cell wall we showed no effect on
cellular proliferation with the cyclone
access as well as no effect on a pop
ptosis of these cells that were labeled
and this just shows the the long
retention in in the various cell lines
of the radio label it's not it's not
reaching back out of the cell because
it's actually covalently bonded to the
cell when we inject these IV into the
mouse you can see here that we have
uptake initially in the lung and some in
the in the bone you can see the
quantitation shown here on this slide
was most the activity in the lung as
these meds and kimmel stem cells are
trapped in the lung
if you give phosphate the free phosphate
it goes mainly to the bone you can see
activities mainly in the bone and a
little bit in liver and no activity in
lung so it's a good confirmation that we
have good cell labeling and the label is
not coming off the DFO in vivo we've
collaborated with some a cardiovascular
investigators including dr. besar and he
is looking at stem cells for
regenerative treatment of the myocardium
after myocardial infarction and he found
that he could sort of reprogram some
bone marrow-derived mesenchymal stem
cells with various growth factors you
can see them here a tgf idea fil
thrombin retinoic acid and when he gives
me all of these as a cocktail he
stimulates a lot of the transcription
factors you can see them here that are
indicative of myocytes and these these
cells he's shown actually bring back the
functional status of the myocardium at
least in a mouse model he's seeing
promotion of ejection fraction after
experimental infarction in these mouse
hearts and he's actually seeing regrowth
of you see mitochondria here in these
infarcted areas as well as the fibrillar
regeneration in the myocytes and if
looking at the ejection fraction so he
took 12 bone marrow samples from 12
different patients that's across the the
the x-axis here and he's looking at the
improvement of ejection fraction in his
mouse model after treatment with these
reprogrammed the stem cells and you can
see the improvement of ejection fraction
is anywhere from ten to forty percent in
this model and here are here is all the
confirmation of the cardio specific
transcription factors
have been rebounded in these cells or i
should say differentiated into these
self and so we looked at where you know
using the the g4 micro pet in our lab we
looked at trafficking of these cells in
his mouse model his in mouth and fark
shin model and we these these cells were
implanted into the myocardium into the
infarcted area of the mouse mark
myocardium and you can see these are the
distributions at two days after
implantation of these cells and most of
the cells stay in the heart as you can
see at the bottom here in the bottom
grafts but they do go elsewhere and this
is really quite interesting they go long
brain that that was that was quite
surprising that many ended up in the
brain in it was a variable across the
across the the mice where these cells
ended up so there's quite a lot of
biological variation at least in this
model of cell trafficking and we did
show that there was functional
improvement whether or not we labeled
these cells with zirconium 89 you can
see at thirty 30 days after the cell
therapy there was an improvement of
ejection fraction in independent of the
labeling of these cells so that was
quite nice and confirming that when
we're not changing the functionality of
the self the indirect method I'll just
speak slowly about that or briefly about
that so the indirect method of cell
labeling can give us functional status
of the self after after implantation or
administration of the cells and in the
the whole idea is putting in reporter
genes into the cells that will express
proteins that then can be read out by
the PET imaging method using a reporter
probe so there's a there's a harvesting
of the cells and and and then the
radionuclide injection after
administration of the cells and you get
the
and then you interpret the pet as a
function of the the stem cells reporting
the gene and there are many different
reporters that are being looked at here
here are several that's probably not
exhaustive a lot of work has been done
with the thymidine kinase the herpes
simplex virus thymidine kinase which is
has many reporter probes here f hbg is
one of the the primary ones but the
others listed here we have to consider
the the normal physiology of the
reporters and what tissue were actually
trying to look at and try to get a good
match of our reporter system with the
the tissue that we're trying to
interrogate for example if we're trying
to look at regenerative of regeneration
of the liver the TK system might not be
the best one because this is the main
route mainly for all of these reporter
genes so we might want to look at
another system that is where the
reporter has a very low uptake in liver
in that case we've worked a lot with the
sodium iodide symporter here at Mayo
Clinic and we use f-18 tfb or
tetrafluoroborate as a reporter for that
system just pros and cons the direct
method of course it has an immediate
imaging signal very high sensitivity for
tracking the cells in the early phase
but no information on cellular viability
there's signal loss over time due to
radionuclide decay the signal may
disassociate from the original cell
whereas indirect has the positive
positive that you can measure cellular
viability and function the cells must be
able to tolerate the transduction
there's high nonspecific signal from
physiological distribution such as the
sex of perfusion transport metabolism on
your reporters so you really have to
consider what is the kinetics and
metabolism of your reporter and the
specific imaging signal is
delayed because it takes some time for
those cells to reproduce and to start
expressing the the reporter protein you
have to factor that into your into your
technique as well and the signal is
dynamic and complex and it there there
are as limitations on the PET scanning
sensitivity to be able to measure small
numbers of cells that are injected and
of course you're depending on the
expression of your reporter if you're if
just as an example of being able to get
a lot of signal out of reporter system
in this case if you take tumors or
cancer cells that are already infected
with the HSV TK as the gene reporter and
you grow a tumor in a mouse here here
you can see the big tumor and if this is
a PET scan of hfh BG lighting up the TK
that's being expressed very highly in
this tumor whereas with stem cells
you're not you have a limited number of
cells in the body in this case this this
study they transfected into the stem
cells the dopamine transporter here d to
ra da and they injected these into the
hind limb of the in the muscle of the
rat excuse me I think this is a mouse
and you can see a very small signal here
its unilateral on the on the side that
that was injected and they followed this
notice that they implanted two times ten
to the seven cells into this muscle so
they were able to see the expression of
the d2 the d2 reporter using the
reporter f-18 labeled of Sally pride
which binds to the d2 system which is
not expressed in normal muscle however
you look at all the the normal
distribution of f-18 Sally pride so this
might not be a good reporter system in
the gut in another
study we look at fh BG with again the TK
system in this case we can see here the
the reporter signal is increasing in
time so here again ha you have 5 times
10 to the million cells injected and it
takes about four to seven days to start
to see the signal to increase this is
indicative of the indirect method you
have to produce enough reporter that the
pet signal isn't going to start to pick
it up and in this case it was after
about four four to seven days in this
study from Washington University labeled
T cells were injected into mice as well
as patients this study was to start to
look at when you have chemotherapy or a
bone disease that you eradicate the the
normal hematopoietic system you then get
a bone marrow transplant and then what
can happen after bone marrow transplant
is a so-called graft-versus-host disease
where the the donor immune cells will
start to interact with the the host and
give you this disease which which can be
deleterious to the health of the
patients so in order to start to
understand the mechanism of this this
graft versus host disease these studies
were labeling this is an indirect
labeling with TK T cells from donor from
donor mice into host mice and then
tracking those with with F hbg you could
see up taking the time Simas here up
here and later this is the normal by a
distribution of F hbg they did initial
pilot studying humans both in patients
with the graft versus host disease and
patients excuse me patients without and
patients with unfortunately they did not
see specific signal for the F hbg in the
study they administered 10 to the 7th
cells and evidence
this was not enough to give a specific
signal on the pet to let them know if
they're there is any signal coming from
these T cells so again this is a
limitation of the indirect method is the
number of cells and that these cells
need to produce the reporter to give you
a specific signal so in conclusions pet
provides sensitive imaging platform for
non-invasive tracking of cells in the
body the cellular toxicity effects are
mitigated by the high specific activity
of labeling with pet isotopes the direct
cell labeling methodologies have been
established for these isotopes f-18
copper and zirconium I think we're going
to see more from manganese as well and
indirect cell labeling has the potential
to provide readout on cell viability and
function but there are technical
challenges to the indirect method and we
have to understand our limitations on
sensitivity there so I want to give
acknowledgments to my group dr. Adachi
bonsall dr. mukesh Pandey dr. ray Jang
in my lab as well as our collaborators
in regenerative medicine and the funding
at NIH and mayo clinic Center for
regenerative medicine and all I'm open
for questions now thank you first we'll
hear our next presentation so thank you
again for your presentation I will now
turn it over to dr. Shipley it's bacon
quiche hello from my side and welcome
everybody to my presentation and hope
for everybody sees the first slide and
as I mentioned we are a collaborative
effort between the three institution the
ETH in Zurich the polar Institute and
the University Hospital and naturally
also we have different emphasis on our
research at these three different sites
and so I going to give you a brief
flavor about our activities in this
respect so looking at the current
Trentham this is the view of a radio
pharmacist in molecular imaging and
medicine and I would identify several
trends at this time and we have
generally be started off with very short
lead isotope like carbon 11 or floor 18
and I see now we have also seen a herd
up from the previous representation the
trend goes that more and more longer
live pet nuclides are used for different
purposes and also because of different
reasons and all the trend is clearly
that fdg which is still the gold
standard in nuclear medicine is not
going to be replaced but it's going to
be supplemented by different traces new
traces which are more specific maybe
also addressing less patient the less
indications but maybe give you a better
picture or close a picture or more
accurate picture on our honor disease
then we have a clear trend from actually
going from diagnosis simply a pet
diagnose your spec diagnosis to into an
area where you have four we have going
from therapy from diagnose you to
therapy and I guess radio
pharmaceuticals are prone example that
you know we can combine diagnostics and
therapeutic indications with one of the
same targeting molecule by simply
switching from from a diagnostic isotope
to a therapeutic isotope and I going to
give you a certain few examples from
from our research this is our current
research activity at the center and
they're not going to talk about every
all these aspects I gotta talk abri flea
about the ice no productions on you
isotopes which could be of interest and
going to talk about the vitamin C used
for cancer diagnosis then two examples
about new Lincoln's for the central
nervous system mainly targeting the
glutamatergic system but also the kind
of we need system and then closing with
an example of our most recent research
area which is the detection of
vulnerable plaques in cardiac disease
what do we have so do actually be to be
able to perform imaging and all these
studies we need to of course preclinical
imaging facilities and devices so we
have currently actually three devices
available there is a super Argus pet-ct
from say DeKalb and we have an
unexpected move used located at the pole
share Institute and we actually have
about a year ago we have bought this g8
pet-ct device from perkinelmer we
decided that you might ask the question
why we decide on buying a new smaller
pet-ct when we have our idea a large one
we were actually intrigued by the
compact size the low weight optima of
the system and particulars about the
sensitivity of this of this new device
and it comes along also with either
integrated x-ray or a CT which also
helps to do morphological images I mean
the idea and actually that was habit
well it was a bit a new concept which I
proposed when we wrote the grant for
forgetting the funding for this new g8
the idea is actually that we with this
new g4 or g8 system because it's so
small we can actually make it mobile why
do we think mobilisation of offer of a
scanner makes sense and particularly in
Europe Britain Switzerland we see the
problem that you have you facing
difficulties and animal studies now
transporting any animals between
different locations is getting more and
more difficult and so I mean and you
need of course if you then have to split
your your study two cohorts one actually
doing a therapy study and the other one
animals have to be you know sent to the
to the pet facility to do the images
this is costly and sometimes also
prohibited for you know if you have
special mice which cannot be transported
or you have mice which need special
attention or special environment it's
difficult to actually convince research
colleagues to also use pet for the
research so the idea that we at the
center we can provide we have a
cyclotrons we have research we have
synthetic radio synthetic facilities and
we have a collage collection actually of
available pet racer from preclinical but
also a clinical application and so the
idea is actually that we we can send the
scanner to the two different groups
which are interested to do images and we
actually sent the scanner along with the
radio traces and one of the one of the
features of this new pet scan is because
it's so because it's also highly
sensitive you actually only need a
c-type laboratory which is available
most of the research laboratories at
least you and historic area so you can
actually install your pets can quite
easily and in this industry and these
laboratories and so the people having
your do conducting the research you know
will have access to the PET scanner for
a period of time you deliver them also
you'll provide them with the pet racer
from our research facility and so they
can actually conduct their research that
improved their research and so that was
one of the was on the argument why we
considered actually looking into buying
a search system so summarizing again so
advances for the user community no
transport of the air and animals between
facilities if access to pet capabilities
which we otherwise would not have if
you're not able to actually bring your
mice out of your facility you reduce the
number of animals for longitudinal
studies you have minimal investment for
actually having your own young scanner
and the last but not least the picture
is worth a thousand words so in also
improves potentially your impact for
publications so and what I'm going to
show you now is a video how we actually
know designed the
concept the video will show how we
designed the cart which is holding the
g8 plus computers plus UPS and
anesthesia facility equipment then we
will see how this got a whole device is
then transported by a court for a truck
from one location to another it also
shows the installation into c-type
laboratory and and well I going to start
now the video hopefully it works I
cannot able I will all be able to speak
over the video so please enjoy and then
I get back to you afterwards
ok it seems like Evernote able
you
you
okay and back so that's basically
showing the transportation from the
polar Institute to the ETH and you can
see that you know it actually quite
nicely you know you can enter any any
comment or in laboratories with this
with this device so i'm going to show
you now a few of the datas which we have
collected with the scanner actually the
first examples which you see here is
actually taken with the chief for which
we installed in 2013 or get for a couple
of month to test what you see here is a
bone scan a fluoride in a mouse very
typical up taking in the bones and we
also have fun that we see here let me
quickly get the arrow here d you see
here the chicken a chicken embryo system
which we used for also detecting or
actually checking the device if it able
to image such small animals and what you
would like to point out is the very low
and activity which we have to inject in
both animals and when it's after 90
minutes you really get clearly a very
nice uptake in this in this site where
fluoride is taken up in the bones second
example was Philippe right we have seen
the pictures with Philippe right before
and the same distribution also here just
wanted to point out that it is we are
able to actually quite nicely see the
small deletion regions where the d2
receptors are expressed so resolution is
actually quite quite reasonable and of
course we see also the normal
distribution of the of the tracer in the
animal we see the also the D
fluorination of the compound in vivo
which is clear then
by the uptake in the poem again here
shows very little activity needs to be
administered and the scan will start a
90 per minute postinjection so it was
actually really a very low activity
which is still in the mouse when these
pictures have been taken and another
example is looking at different isotopes
so there is a here the mouse can which
was with injected with folic acid
derivative here even go here a bit more
about that in a minute so this holy gas
derivatives has been functionalized with
a no taki rating system where suitable
for gallium and copper labeling and you
see here the animals a demo so this is
now taking this to g8 so you see here
also the CT which is a overlay to the
PET scans and just to show that there is
actually you see the typical differences
in resolution between gallium and and
also copper due to the lower better plus
energy so clearly also in this g8
scanner you can nicely see the
differences in the resolution and of
course copper 64 later time points or
did you better uptake is also seeing
here in the nice update can also be seen
here in the choreo plexus even a very
small areas in the brains which are made
to be able to be visible with this with
this scanner when we talk about new
isotopes I mean I see here to show you
the map here of Switzerland and in red
you see actually the nuclear medical
department in Switzerland you see in
green also the psychotron distribution
where PET scans pet traces are
manufactured and produced and for f-18
labeled compound the logistics of quite
reasonable over the red circle basically
represents the area where you can kiss
you
you'd on a commercial basis with your
your compound but of course if you go
for gallium 68 which is these days very
fashion so people use gallium 68 or
promoted very very heavily I think it's
a very nice isotope but if we consider
that form a logistic point of view ER
for you from from that you know
decentralized production it is with a
nightmare so you can hardly distribute
this sort of the isotope to out to other
facilities to other hospitals so his
room of improvement you'll be looking
actually into other isotopes so I
mentioned copper 64 already there is a
turbulent 152 which are going to speak
in a minute and there's also scandium 44
with roughly four hour half life which
is somehow between copper and floor 18
and this of course gives you a much
broader range of delivery of your
compounds not only for preclinical
research but also of course for clinical
development and Oh significant clinical
use and we also tested those isotopes if
the new g8 assistant because it produces
isotopes in process I'm usually a
Porsche execute and the scanner was is
basically located to poor share
Institute scandium 44 is an attractive
isotope as I mentioned and they're
actually quite easily produced there you
see here the production out can start
from from enrich calcium 44 PN reaction
and the intriguing feature is that you
can actually produce that at the low
energy cyclotrons or any standard
medicalized psychotron can produce this
at this isotope I show you here the
targa tree which we developed here so
it's basically enriched calcium
carbonate which is used we have here now
five to ten milligrams and enrichment is
mild ninety-four percent of calcium 44
and we actually mount this compound or
this this calcium carbonate
on a graphite layer and then seal that
in this aluminum capsule you see the
very thin layer of the calcium carbonate
and to irradiate that for a couple of
minutes half an hour roughly and we get
actually quite a decent yield so we are
producing 50s amount of material with a
radiation time of roughly 30 minutes up
to 2 Giga bacterials of calcium of
scandium 44 we use the scandium 44 for
proof of concept with dota knock so as
an artist at teen reset the targeting
peptide again here this is taken with
the g8 system we have low amount of
activity again injected into this dis
Mouse it's only one megabyte carell
three hours post-injection you see
actually a distribution which resembles
very much you see high up taking the
tumors and regular distribution which is
very close to for example lutetium 177
dr. Ngoc peptide so scanty ma is
therefore also excuse me is also a good
surrogate isotope for doing pre therapy
diagnosis and also though symmetry
because it actually resemble chemistry
samples very much the lanthanides
speaking about line tonight we also
looked into a quite interesting and set
of isotopes based on the element terbium
is it actually a turbulence wants a few
elements we have four different isotopes
which are suitable for diagnosis and
therapy so we have on one hand in the
turbulent 149 for our for our half-life
which is alpha immature we have the
ytterbium 152 which roughly is 17.5
hours of life
is a better plus emitter we have
ytterbium 155 which is a pure gamma
emitter and we have the turban 161 which
is a better minus emitter and also has
actually additional oj electrons quite a
substantial amount of oj electrons which
are committed and it's actually quite
nice isotope because it has it's very it
resembles very much lutetium 177 so you
can actually you know if you do
therapies that is quite well distinguish
between the effect of oj s vs. pure
better- therapy so it is considered oh I
also always call it actually the Swiss
Army knife for radio pharmacy in nuclear
medicine because actually can cover all
the aspects of therapy and diagnosis
today was just talk briefly about the
diagnostic application so this is again
a somatostatin analogue which has been
labeled with turbulent 152 for pet
imaging again is GH canon has been used
for this purpose you see here the
distribution after 24 hour and year
after 32 hours and again the low
activity has been injected scanned
duration about 30 minutes and the longer
half-life or the long half-life actually
allows us to have a late time point you
see clearly and improved to more to
kidney ratios or the tumors are quite
substrate retain the activity whereas
the the rest of the activity clears
quite quickly from from this mouse again
you know this was being be enabled by ER
this scanner which could be mobilized
and placed at the polar Institute a very
interesting story actually which was
recently published and with the
turbulent 149 I mentioned this is alpha
emitter attacks actually has a very
small portion of beta plus emission
about only seven percent of the
intensity you can actually you know not
even to therapy we did
some therapeutic stories with this alpha
emitter quite successfully but we also
can actually do diagnosis and you see
here we injected roughly seven maker
backers of this somatostatin analog in
the mouse and you can clearly concede
the uptake or the pet images which could
show the high uptake in India to Moores
and so this is I would say tell agnostic
at it its best or you can do really
though symmetry with with pet images and
also do therapy it before not the same
isotope a very rare example actually so
when I switch now from talking about the
scanner more about our own research
different research areas which we are
currently working on so
neurodegenerative diseases we my
colleague the professor a meta my at the
eth she is very much engaged into
development of traces for the
glutamatergic system so neural death is
often observed as a cascade starting
from membrane depolarization elevated
koultimate levels over stimulation of
the glutamate receptor calcium overload
and the good old turkic system is
involved in several diseases like
schizophrenia anxiety depression
Parkinson's Alzheimer's disease you name
it so it's really a very broad
indication for such traces several years
ago and my colleague has developed the
carbon 11 derivative c c11 ATP 688 has
been used in several studies and around
the world and also in Syria with it many
studies one of these is shown on this
best light wary who actually started in
sleep deprived volunteers you could
clearly see the uptake of low uptake the
reduced uptake of the tracer in actually
normal up taking in the wake / people
and then in sleep sleep deprived
patients or volunteers you clearly can
see an upregulation of the
tropical termite receptor subtype 5 and
this is was a carbon 11 compound we
wanted to go actually to us out and
deliver the tracer to different centers
so we were developing or we tried to
develop a carbon 11 compound so this is
now on the top row you see again the red
study using the carbon 11 compound and
you see actually below the floor 18
derivatives we actually tested to
several compound a large series of
compounds have been developed and tested
and this was finally that the PSS 232
which and all shows the features which
we would want to have for further
clinical development you see and the
same uptake in the area where the
glutamatergic system is in order the
receptors are expressed here in the area
of those rats we developed this into GMP
conditions and you see here now the
volunteer study which has just freed
fairly recently being finalized in
zurich on the right on the left side you
see the benchmarks of the carbon 11 AVP
compound which has been published and on
the right side you see now the study
with the flow rate in compound a
compound which is virtually shows
similar distribution and of course to
also to the to the better DK properties
the resolution is significantly better
than into carbon 11 compound so with
that we have started already to you a
new studies in the Zurich area and of
course we are more than happy also to
provide and all the center's basically
with precursors also if you know how to
where they want to would like to use
them another area which we started to
work on estacada when you eat to see a
system so particular interest in economy
2 receptor subtype to its compared to
the cb1 the column b 26 receptor 2 a 1
which is expressed dominantly in the
brain
it's actually cb2 is only expressed in
the periphery and only under very
certain curves specific conditions it's
up straight regulated so for example
under multiple sclerosis Alzheimer
disease and I'm going to throw quick
lateral sclerosis and of course we
actually restored the work in
collaboration with ALS Center in in
Switzerland of course a prominent
patient suffering from a less Stephen
Hawkins and so we were really intrigued
tour we were actually motivated to
develop such cb2 receptor ligand for
eventually diagnosis of ALS and look for
prevail disease progression and may
eventually also therapy and monitoring a
number of cb2 receptor ligands has been
reported today where the variable
success tested in vivo and some of them
have shown that they actually are PGP
substrate so there's a lower brain
uptake some of them are shown a lower
metabolic stability and on the very
lower left corner you see the abbot
compound which is the most promising but
again it's a carbon 11 compound which
needs aunt and kind of you know having
the patient just next to the cyclotron
and this was actually a published a
couple of years ago was this kindle in
derivatives which shows a quite a nice
selectivity between cb1 and cb2 so we
took this as a lead structure for the
development of a carbon 11 and
eventually also called floor 18
compounds i'm going actually quickly
back so there's two positions which seem
to be interesting and able to be
functionalized with isotope we have here
the position for the carbon 11 which we
actually also performed developed and
there's also of course at this position
you could imagine that you can introduce
your floor 18 that's what we have done
and you see here the development of this
floor 18 compound DC or
as one to six which shows the
appropriate conditions and features for
actually in vivo studies or selectivity
is high affinity is good and they're
pharmacokinetic was also proven to be
optimal or being favorable we did some
studies actually in ALS patient spinal
cord section you see that on this slide
very clearly can see that there is
specific uptake of the tracer in the
areas of the spinal cord and this
specific update can be blocked with a
cold compound in excess so we are hope
we hope that this compound or these
least structure is now on the way to go
into patients and for to the first
patient studies with a CB a suitable cb2
receptor ligand so switching from CNS
now to some examples from cancer so of
course there's a lot of hype of psma
based ligands for prostate cancer
diagnosis and therapy and of course it's
addresses mainly or exclusive
exclusively of course man cancer which
is expressed in men but there's another
fifty percent population on the world
which is also suffering from cancer and
so we are looking into traces which
could address kansas which are
specifically expressed or overexpressed
or common in eden female patients and
the folate receptor seems to be in this
respect quite interesting target because
the default reset is overexpressed in a
number of cancer type which is which
with higher frequency and there are also
therapies available these days
antibodies which are targeting folate
receptor for cancer therapy and
therefore there is a need of developing
diagnostic traces for a selection of
patients suitable for a therapy again he
is about about sixty seventy six percent
of all cancer types to actually
overexpress the whole intercept at one
of the time of development for a
receptor alpha the isoform which is
overexpressed on the cancer cells
specifically can be specifically target
with the oxidized form of folic acid
which is shown on the right top it has
actually two position or you can see
from the x-ray structure of them of the
receptor you can clearly see that the
carboxylic acid of the glutamate point
out of the structure so you can
potentially functionalize the molecule
at these two positions this is actually
done with a number of compounds also
[ __ ] chemotherapeutics and also radio
labeled with radio labels and we see
that on the next slide there's actually
two approaches you can actually
introduce the isotope order i am the
floor 18 at the gamma carboxylic acid
alpha or the gamma carboxylic acid or
folic acid and all you can do it
alternatively and that's what we also
tried to incorporate the floor 18th of
the so-called integrated approach to
actually incorporate the floor 18
directly into the lead structure this on
the next slide you see the development
of such compounds in our laboratory you
see on the bottom left you see the first
pendant approach so at attachment of
prosthetic fluorine any comp as groups
at the gamma carboxylic acid and then on
the two top structures you see here now
the introduction of the isotope into the
least drug into folic acid directly here
on this benzene ring or here with this
into disappeared in ring and I'll show
you on the next slide distribution or
that in vivo testing of the compounds
clearly the first generation showed in
favorable uptake in the abdominal region
you can see the tumors on the left and
the right of the shoulders of the of the
mouse but clearly there's a high
abdominal
take which is not favorable then we have
to first integrated approach in a
compound which actually shows quite nice
uptake low background activity there's
up taking in a kidney which is quite
normal but still good there was the
issue about the synthesis of the
synthesis clearly not optimal for this
compound low radiochemical yield and so
the an alternative was now or the
alternative was now to develop better
compile precursor which could be more
easily in radial able to hire
radiochemical yield and this is called
the SFO late you see that there is tumor
uptake clearly seen but also a bit of a
higher background activity in the label
but this was compound was nevertheless
choosing for actually going forward and
this last compound is whereas we just
shown you if now in clinical studies a
critical sorry ass not in zurich and is
still ongoing so now switching to the
last topic we're running out of time so
cardiovascular disease and we gotta look
at the hallmark of archers chlorosis and
there are number of targets which has
been identified over the last year's
nevertheless the Holy Grail in audiology
is indeed that we have to somehow this
to be able to distinguish between
vulnerable and stable plaques and not
all of these targets actually do this to
English evolved and stable plaque so we
looking particularly at the new targets
0 4 against receptor beta is one of the
targets I highlighted in red and I gotta
talk briefly about cd18 cd86 you see
here the two potential new targets ed
AT&T dat six member of the email
grumblings family regulatory regulates
the t cell activity and it actually has
been identified by US and other groups
to be actually also overexpressed in
vulnerable plaques we actually
get the human samples directly from the
surgery so we could we have normal
auditory stable plaques and multiplex
which are scored according to this with
this different features infiltration of
immune cell size of lipid necrotic or
driver's cab thickness and fibrous cap
rupture so that's a the level of
expression on the mRNA level of cd8 and
cd86 you could clearly see a high
overexpression of the mRNA level in the
vulnerable plaques compared to normal
plaques so this is clearly indicating
that there could be an interesting
target we have done also mrna levels on
other targets and have never seen such a
significant overexpression or the
difference between involve and stable
plaques there are only a few small
molecules which are suitable for florid
18 labeling for this target you see here
this first the compound which is has
been tested in our laboratory and we see
here on the next slide also the ex vivo
autoradiography and you could clearly
see that the floor 18 compound is nicely
located actually nicely has a high
uptake in the vulnerable plaques way
actually has a very low uptake in normal
arteries or in stable plaques and you
can also this place this up take off the
tracer with blocking and with blocking
agents so we hope that with this you
know that actually would be a nice
target we are currently also improving
with the pharmacokinetics of this
compound because my all studies have
shown that it actually clears quite
quickly from from from the blood pool
with that I would like to wrap up and
say I think there's more to come in
terms of new pet races and also pet
isotopes beside floor 18 and fdg and I
think it's very important that
preclinical imaging facilities and
capabilities are made available for a
broader research community and I think
that the small and compact g8 system
from PerkinElmer would be
an excellent tool for actually making
this technology available for more for
broader scientific community thanks very
much and also more than happy to take
questions now thank you both for your
informative presentations it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. degrade or dr. should we please
do so now just click on the green to an
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box appears on your screen and
click on the send button will answer as
many of your questions because we have
time for electric its target here first
question for dr. Greider is what a pet
MRI is an emerging technology do you see
applications that would benefit from MRI
compared to pet CT yes I would they the
MRI allows you know very good anatomic
registration of the pet especially in
soft tissues so if you're you know if
you have small structures that are being
targeted by the labeled cells you know
it would provide a superior and atomic
registration for that I I would not
expect we would be dual labeling the
cells though if that's what you meant
dual labeling with iron and some type of
pet probe I wouldn't do that but yeah
anatomic registration dr. Shirley would
you speak to this question to you and
let me know if you'd like me to repeat
it so it means that the same question as
was off before yes well I signing out I
just agree agree what what the bottom
has said you know okay great how long
does it take to get the mobi PET scanner
up at each site in terms of minutes
hours Oh doctor should we yes yes and
actually it's actually quite quickly go
get up mean we can and everything is
mounted on this on this card so a power
supply everything set up of course you
have to make sure that the calibration
is made before you start the PET scans
and it is a bit of training
to bring this up but i would say in half
a day european as we said and you can
actually start to do your experiment how
do you know the labeled cells are alive
in vivo in other words how do you know
the labeled cells are functional during
tracking and that is for dr. Greider
that's that's a really good question
really it's only the indirect labeling
method that where you get a functional
read out because the the cells must
express the report reporter protein
that's that's when you know for sure you
have a live a cell and in the direct
labeling method you don't know whether
your label has you know it well you
don't know whether the cell remains
viable or not you know the label is is
where you see it in the pet image so we
we got at it by doing functional
measurements that we knew these cells
affected they recovered the the ejection
fraction in our mouse heart model and we
saw that there was no difference between
you know labeled cells and non labeled
cells they both gave the same amount of
recovery so that was I guess you would
say an indirect proof that the cells
function had not been degraded by the
labeling here we are almost out of time
so this will have to be our last
question for dr. Shipley are there any
safety concerns would use some
longer-lived Radio isotopes in a lab I
presume the longer life helps with
aspects such as logistics for instance
transport well actually I do not see a
big difference between longer-lived eyes
dope in short the size of isotopes of
course I mean we still talking about
only a few days off lines and and so I
do not really see a bit concerned about
that same here we we don't have any
large concerns based on half-life thank
you i would like to once again
dr. dre told dr. Shipley for their
presentation if you have any final
comments not really well we will be
answering the other questions offline
thank you thank you once again I would
also like to thank our sponsor
perkinelmer for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 15
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay we sure
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and also please note that you can
continue to submit questions to dr.
Dubrow and dr. Shipley during the
on-demand period that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon why